so
welcome back to another episode of
bleacher reports pre-game
pitch the only show in the world with
you the people at home
can win free cash prizes by simply
predicting
all the random [ __ ] that occurs in the
nba pregame
as always i am your host pierre aka pee
with the plug and today i am joined by
my boy the one and only famous lost
lois what's popping dog boy you eggless
hell
what up though
what y'all yes sir with y'all
you ready to get this [ __ ] out y'all i
call p.s
self
your ass is patrick beverly jr [ __ ] you
talking about
no but let's get to the prompt and let's
see everything that we got going on for
tonight
with me and my boy lois first and
foremost lost
i know before we got a cracking you said
you was a fashionista we got
what will zyon rock to the arena
secondly
we got who x is the turtle the tunnel
first jaw or dylan brooks
third we have the overall under 18 and a
half shots for
for zion and the warm-ups that's a
little too high and then last but not
least we have make or miss
final shot of the pelicans warm-up which
one you like the most out of these four
talk to me lois
and now we're about to get hey lois we
got something special for you lois that
you ain't know what's cooking we got
your pre-game warm-up
i don't know if you know we got this
let's roll this show lots what we got
post what is this what is this bro
what you was listening to
you showing off you showing off the
bling i want to know what you was
listening to though
what song what song was that
yeah we lost his mic i don't know listen
i don't know what loss was listening to
he over on the west side of the map
maybe he was into some yg
maybe listen to some tupac i don't know
but the first thing we're going to get
into is what will zion
wear to the arena that is what we're
waiting on right now
while my boy loves get his issue set up
i told you he's patrick beverly jr
he might have been chewing on his wire
you might have been i can hear you can
you hear me
young patrick beverly can you hear me
yeah i can hear you back
come on man what what you doing you
chewing on the mic all right
[ __ ] you look like you look like jamal
murray come on back let's go y'all come
on man
hey let's get let's get to what zion is
rocking to the arena please for the
people at home
so we can get to see who is taking that
money
to the crib lois come on man i don't i
don't want to have no more technical
difficulties
so we we got we got zion oh zion blamed
up
zion blinded up i see him boys i'm
biggest you say it's fake
hey why is that bigger than the security
hey you guessed it too you guessed it
before
we said zion was going to come with the
hoodie nothing sooner than booty
you hit it right on the head yeah
so we got what was zion right to the
hoodie where would he rock to the arena
we have zion rocking the hoodie
we got five winners taken home the cash
prizes shout out to my boy bentley
underscore b
for predicting what zion will be rocking
to the arena
which was the hoodie next up we have who
exits the tunnel first john moran or
dylan brooks
this one right here might be a little
this this is a little hard i ain't gonna
lie to you
this is i don't really watch a lot of uh
who who watched the channel first
dylan he the best player on the team
does it make sense hey you a warriors
fan
you love steph curry steph curry go out
of the tunnel first we did an episode a
couple weeks ago and steph curry was the
first one out of the tunnel
that was two that was one game but see
you ain't know that [ __ ] cause you're
just talking come on pat daddy
come on one game and it's different when
steph curry says
i'm sorry i was looking at you i called
you seth i was trying i was talking
about stuff
got to score 60. steph got to score 60.
so you got to get that uh split cat
ready that's the difference
hey look i was listening to famous don't
worry i was listening to famous lows
song called don't worry that's what i
was dancing to in the beginning y'all
throw that back on there bingo
okay okay cool so that my boy was this
his own song i like that that way let's
say his own song
hey so listen so you taking john marant
you taking john moran you taking dylan
brooks for whatever you take
i'm going the opposite well you're a
hater that's why but dylan walking out
first
okay so i'm rocking with john moran give
me john moran hey what they
hey can i get a can i get a camera a
camera view of what they doing right
there what are they doing right here
are they setting up chairs is he set up
chairs
that's what you would be doing if you
was there
i guess guess what you'll be doing we we
won't know because you'll be there after
the game and sweeping up the stands
no i won't i'll be walking out but i'll
be walking out behind y'all
no you would no you when you don't even
play for that team you play for the
clippers
hey listen how
we got 17 we got 17 minutes left how
many chairs
do you think my boy can can set up in
the next minute
uh and the next minute we got a minute
how many chairs he's not even doing it
for real but give me ten
no hell no five is it hold on wait we're
gonna do it
one night what are we starting
i wanna know no no no we're gonna start
counting at 16.45
how many chairs can they set up in a
minute
all right 10. this between me and you 10
yes okay
i'm gonna say i'm gonna i'm going less
than ten i'm going less than ten give me
seven hey
i'm gonna say seven so the clock the
clock starts
we got 10 on the line what we got so you
are you keep it count though
that's two that's one that's two four
that was four
that was two that's true hold on
hold on hold on watch let's see
there you go there you go there you go
thank you
my boy stevo got us stevo going to show
us oh dylan
dylan went out first i told you why
would y'all
the first four people was the same
people the first three people was the
same people
we're not doing that no you're not gonna
talk down you're not gonna talk down on
the light skin
you're not gonna talk down on light skin
t relax just pump your brakes pat bear
pray the whole left side light skin
get out of here bring them dogs we're
the dark skinned killers up here look at
him
look at him look at him south carolina
that's a carolina boy y'all look at them
closely
yes shout out to characters that's
another one
that's another one hey yeah shout out
for those at home that don't know
my boy lois is from the carolina area so
shout out to them carolina boys
the next prop that we do have is the
over or under 18 and a half shots
for zion uh in pregame can we show the
winners
of who comes out of the tunnel first can
we can we get love to the winners
because i was wrong i was wrong
so we got we got jackson we got jacko
uh and we got sheesh so shout out to
them boys for for picking the right
answer
i don't even want to get no love to lose
because he cheated
lost no no dylan brooks so dylan brooks
had told him that before the game he'd
be coming out first
i ain't know i ain't no i know start
stars because
those used to be a star so no stars
hey we so we keeping track of zion
i want to know your answer mr bat they
don't know we had a pre
a pre-show you know little sit-down man
you was talking for a while doing our
thing and you was talking like you know
basketball i still don't know if i can
give you that approved what not you know
a thing or two
you know i don't know if you know it
like me but you know a thing or two how
many shots zion going over or under 18
and a half
hey explain it to me spain let me
explain that to me what overnight to me
is he getting 19 shots or less than 19
shots
less than 19 shots he's not about taking
90 shots at one most
that's one cool so i okay
so you you're gaining my trust a little
bit a little bit with the next because
that's what i said you heard me say that
in pre-production i said i don't think
zion ain't gonna need to take that
amount of shots but uh
he already i'm watching something i'm
watching some weird stuff though
this man just shot from the right side
and the left-hand side when did they do
that
who did that okay oh wait they swear
they they must have just switched right
after
remember right design shot from the
right one
yeah see now i think you was lying about
all that [ __ ] you were saying before the
show about you playing for this team
you played against brandon you're
playing against that
you ain't even know you ain't even know
that they switch
they switch lines on the layup line yeah
why would they switch lines
after one layup because he started on
the wrong side
you wouldn't know that we played no
we're late
we're late on the film we're late on the
film all right i seen nothing six shots
listen while we while we wait on zion to
potentially make
18 shots talk to me about your playing
days because you did tell me before the
show
you played against who seth curry you
played against brandon ingram reggie
pull up
come on talk to me about them days
because i don't think
i don't think a lot of people i don't
think they i don't think they know that
about you they just think you're a funny
dude
but you you know according to some of
the sources that i have you kind of got
a bag you can get it too i don't know if
you can
you can you know mess with me i think
i'll bust your ass
but that's the light skin [ __ ] talking
that's your life inside talk if me and
you are ever on the same court
whenever this pandemic would ever stop
dawg i'm telling you
i'm busting your ass you a little guy
i'm six four
you're in a pokemon this is the most
pointless [ __ ] i've ever had to listen
to in my life
you can't beat me bro i don't even know
if you could play basketball well i know
for a fact
you can't beat me bro i just disappeared
it's in my blood it's in my blood it's
in my bloodline
that's my mom you don't have to be when
i'm gonna be dead ass with you bro i'm
gonna just be dead
with you your name gotta be outdoor you
have to have a literally a damn jersey
on right now
to [ __ ] with me all right like seriously
like seriously no say that again
say it one more time you cut out cause
you were chewing on your mic
you lit i'm not chewing on [ __ ] pulse
but
you literally you literally you
literally have to have a jersey on right
now
or you have to play somewhere and put
numbers up there i'm not talking about
no just playing somewhere
but what you ain't intimidating me what
the hell are you doing
i got my jersey on
shout out to kazzo javon
hey what up that's my boy that's my boy
guru that's my boy jay burke
i call him a every time every time he
bring the ball on the court javon
i call him my boy jay bird javon nice as
hell
and i'll be bragging about him to my boy
jay but he like he could score like that
he played defense he played defense
because i'm like
have you not been watching this man
we got hey before i get to that we got
zion back shooting shots he already had
five
we got about 10 11 minutes he he might
what what i just seen him i just i've
seen him i've seen him airball kind of
but he's good he's straight
oh he didn't okay hands down i
i often say you need to put a pen pass
yes without a doubt without a doubt yeah
yeah you're starting to fight for the
all-star game
he in the west what the f oh no you
don't even know
what he is another confidence come on
what
where's new orleans at
it's in the south but they're in the
west
why would they be why would they be in
the west okay okay
but uh you said uh uh the west the west
star five
steph yeah leblanc okay steph
um dave is it uh paul
uh uh paul george no
kawaii kawhi kauai um
uh or this day or
yeah you about to say it dang you bout
to say it damn
probably damn right dave yeah who am i
missing
too damn fast hey hey zion back shooting
i want to do something called
side action i like it sad action
is something we gonna do where i want to
know how many shots i hopefully he
continues to shoot these shots
how many shots can zion make in the next
minute just these right here
these jump shots in the next minute
yes
we not keeping track i want you to guess
predict
like the people at home been doing all
day on a bleach report app they've been
predicting a pre-game pick so they could
take home some money
i want you to predict and i want the
people at home to leave in the comments
you so he got six you got six
okay i'm gonna get some time for the
people at home
to let me know what they think famous
those got six
do y'all have six are y'all over y'all
under where are y'all late
let me know in the comments and if we
can
show me some of those comments i'm gonna
get to it in like the next 15 seconds
because look zion this is hey this
something i know is too lost
by doing this these nba players we try
to look cute
you see him with that handle taking this
look at him fake laughing
look at him like like he'll know the
camera on him
exactly like he don't know the camera
hey can we get the clock
let's start let's start the clock let's
start the 60 seconds with zion
he got the first shot look at him he
about to waste the 60 seconds about
talking man he bout to be talking
and [ __ ] man okay uh-huh
yeah look out he know the camera on him
he know the camera on him
look at him hey miss
come on hold up you
you're what with that that's two that's
two
that's who i told you what brandon
ingram is
brandon ingram right there right in
front of him taking taking little
13-footers you see bran with that
headband
that's north carolina we see slender man
that we are yes sir
kingston's finest yes yeah you right
hey hey man hey 10 seconds
hey no no i'm sorry man
ain't no ain't no ain't no alpha you
first you pissed six
three three so you picked six it was
below six it was three
hey you tried you tried but i'm telling
you these players when they get in these
layup lines and they these warm-ups they
be trying to look cute they know that
yup uh-huh how many count we gotta hear
you count
count you gotta
hey by the way me and you both said that
18 shots was too much he already got 14
with six minutes left so hopefully he
continue to you know
try to be cute and do do [ __ ] like this
i don't know what that was
damn man man come on man it's been 20
minutes i hope he hit 18.
have you met zion i know you'll be
around you know you'll be around have
you met zion
my hollywood my hollywood friend have
you met him i know you'd be you know
you'd be with chris brown
you be with me i ironically
i i was one of the first people to do
zion videos and you know it's crazy i've
never met zion
i just thought about that yeah i don't
think i ever seen i don't know
i don't think i've ever seen him be
honest with you
you ain't never seen him what's he at uh
was he at all-star weekend last year
zion's at all stuff yeah yeah i think he
was at all-star weekend that's when i
think i i've never met him though
i never met him yeah who the who the
best player that you've ever met
i played all-star last year uh the best
player i ever met demario curry
but we talk about nba
now i'm telling my professional hey hey
we hey we almost at 18 bro
i'm hoping this man don't get over 18.
i'm hoping he don't get it
hey so what happened look so do the
people win or lose if he get 18 over 18.
it's whatever they voted no i bet i'm
with them
that's what that look hey here we go
you're not looking out for me
i'm not looking out for me if you bet
over 18 with me i love you
i love you but if if you win against me
you're a hater
you're a hater with this with uh with
self dirty
come on man hey you're gonna have me
you're gonna have no no no no no no no
no don't take it back don't take your
pet don't do not take it back
i'm gonna be on your ass like a diaper
for the next oh
i'm telling you you and you easy too you
easy
hey i just can't get rid of the patrick
beverly that show looking like for real
you got that patch
hey if i if i was a stranger i would
have thought you from chicago you got
the patrick beverly tony allen
rough look you look like a chicagoan
south side of chicago
you win stripes you win striker so i
already don't trust you bro you you
you wear a plaid you're a golf player
bro come on man
come on man come on man hello hey you
know what your voice
it looked like it supposed to be uh uh
jello
zoe you did mellow
[ __ ] hey
but you know you know what your boy you
know what your boy stephanie doing in
his off days though he be golfing
better ask about it come on man it's a
rich man sport that's what this man is
hey look hey look i tried not to focus
on zion because i've been watching him
miss
the boy we didn't focus yeah he missed
it
so yeah let's distract ourselves because
i i i want the under i like being right
i don't care if it's my money or not i
like being right
i like that hey what what you eat what
you eat for breakfast what you eat for
breakfast today distract me so we
the more we don't watch him the more he
missed tell me what you ate for
breakfast
uh nothing why i told you my movers came
here but i really i located
in two days look at zion driving that
damn ball i located ben
you do his hair did you see that entry
point wow he passing
he passing yeah we might win this one we
might win
we gonna win this [ __ ] we're gonna win
this [ __ ] but look but think about this
hey but it got he has to take another
shot before one minute because you're
gonna leave on the shot anyway you feel
me
but now he's doing some dumb ass entry
pass that he's never gonna throw
juan herman gomez
ain't that herman gomez i think that's
her mango man or willy herman gomez my
bad willie
willie herman gomez we have six we have
16 though we have 16 we still under
for those that y'all did at home listen
again this is the only show in the world
where you can win
free cash prizes by simply predicting
random [ __ ] that occurs in the nba
pregame
right now me and my boy famous lost we
are we are predicting the over
under of zion on 18 and a half shots we
both got the under zion at 16 but
chilling at 16 for the past three
minutes
my boy doing entry passes right now so
lois
hey a minute 30 we looking good baby
we're looking good why is he throwing it
back
i can guarantee you he's gonna throw one
injury pass today period
only one if one one if that one for sure
and this is the second game i've done of
zion
[ __ ] he made it [ __ ] yes right
next time hold on next time you shoot
i'm gonna say
that's hot you you know why he's making
it now cause we focused on them
we down to the last minute man we're
down to the last minute
it's hard not to focus now cause there's
a minute left now it's getting closer
i know one damn thing that i do to his
head
hey another thing our last challenge is
will the pelicans end or make a miss so
we got to make sure we watch it for that
too
hopefully zion is taking the last for
both of them
because i don't think zion getting this
he back
you think so it's gonna be a make
nobody's gonna walk away uh
off of uh the last rest of my miss
that's not gonna happen
somebody's gonna make a layup hey i said
i said the same thing but last week it
was a miss it ended on a miss
i know they they tell you never never
end on the miss
always end on the make but the rockets
ended on a miss i don't
i don't know what type of operation they
running but they ended on a miss
yeah and we got 15 seconds left they
ain't have to take me there
hey 10 seconds left and anybody taking
somebody ain't going to miss
and if you take a shot he's going to
miss lolo
let's go let's go i knew it i knew that
was too much
i knew that was too much under 18. let's
go
let's go hey what about what about the
last shot is steven that's
[ __ ] shooting somebody going still
they might do national anthem was that a
hey you're right
layup the layup you're right they ended
up making delay was that john's heart
the job bring it back guys oh damn i
missed it
oh no one more time bring it back for my
boy low we got two lows we got you lois
one more sh can we replay that last shot
for my boy we want to double check the
result before we hand out
before we hand out this money here you
go lois replay right here like you said
lay up yes sir and on the map hand it to
you boy y'all good go ahead and get up
out of here that's right that's how
basketball supposed to go right there
you heard me can we see the windows
hey now now i know that you know
basketball because that's how that's how
they teach you
and on the make you gotta end on the
mate
why are you why he do that boy like that
you wanna know what's funny about this
all right this is my first merch this is
my first merch ever
i don't even remember saying this but
when i when i when i moved down with obj
he said it
odell beckham said it and you you better
you better send me something
i know that yeah i got you hey shout out
to these winners shout out to these
winners
oh it's true tom larson they was rocking
with us they took the under
and then on the make or miss last shot
for the pelicans we got chris m taking
home some money
we got professor 615 taking home some
money
you too can be just like them all you
got to do is get on that beach report
app
and get in your pre-game picks all my
winners make sure y'all
are checking that app and checking your
dm so you can get your money i don't
want to wake up and me and lose i
getting hate tweets or hate
posts about y'all not getting y'all
money so check your app check your dm
so you can get that cash now talk to me
obj said that
yeah so i would talk to you about me oh
when i pulled up and i i was in l.a
i pulled up to me oh odell and um his
best friend ben adon you'll see him on
instagram ben and i
and i'm getting out of the car i've
never met them before in my life they
like
why he do that boy like that why are you
doing that like that why are you i'm
like
i'm like why why the hell are they
saying that what the why they saying
how they saying that maybe maybe i sound
like that i don't know i'm just meeting
them anyway i'm just meeting these
people anyway
so i'm uh right i guess so but they said
but every
i walked into house von miller was there
he said it sterling shepard he was
saying it
oh daddy was saying people were saying
i'm like well maybe that's what i know
now you got some bingo i just know
you better have mine you better have
matt hey next thursday
the next versus lakers
kyrie lebron that's gonna be a nice one
so we got that for next thursday
or this thursday i'm sorry not next
thursday this thursday
lakers verse the nets i don't know who
i'm rocking with with that but i know
that's gonna have a lot of interesting
prompts
we out though lost great
great episode my brother we got zanya
rocking the hoodie
like you predicted let's see how many
you got right now i mean you got wrong
for your first one
two you got dylan one two dylan brooks
two right that's two that's two
under on ziya
let's go stay pretty let's get it
hey man this dude right here look at
this hey yo
hey y'all
i love it
huh
you